let's go to Cassidy Jaylen you guys
trailed by as much as 21 in this game
what F your largest comeback win of the
season
um I mean we just stuck together
honestly a fan looked at me in my eye
over here and said this is embarrassing
so uh I'll say him wow uh and so that's
what motivated you in that fourth
quarter is sure okay we'll go with that
can you just walk me through that final
defensive play what was going through
your mind when you saw that ball leave
Jimmy Butler's hand uh um if it's all re
rebound the ball I mean he's a great
player I mean he does a lot of clutch
things so um just happy he missed it but
I got to make free throws you may give
credit to that fan but a lot of credit
also goes to your bench as it was a huge
Advantage 37 to 24 but how would you
specifically describe the spark that
Emanuel quickly gave you guys I mean the
bench including him they they're
fantastic they're the best bench in the
league in my opinion um what they do
night in night out nothing St
spectacular so um I mean the only reason
we wion this game you know without their
run without their spark we don't win the
game and you guys are still alive in the
inseason tournament big win on your home
court H how big did this win feel
tonight I mean having the deficit we did
and coming back it uh it means a lot but
uh I mean we shouldn't have been in that
position in the first place but uh I'm
just happy our bench really got us out
of it and um a lot of credit to them
congrats on the win thank
you